who goes on their vacation with like
it's like
this x's together thing is amazing i'm
super so impressed by it how do you do
it i think the real part is life is a
challenge
and if you work at what you want you can
get it oh
he's getting it getting flirty with his
ex kourtney kardashian on instagram
i feel like yeah hey the reality star
posted
this super sexy photo of herself in a
silver one-piece swimsuit on monday
courtney captioned the shot lekia posing
on a bow in the middle of a lake
and he loves it yeah he does scott got
in on that pun
commenting wait for it what a laker what
is happening here
can we just cut the bs and make hashtag
squirt happen again
i think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
this isn't the first time the friendly
exes caught our attention on the gram
courtney made headlines when she posted
this pic
yeah looked super innocent with a baby
goat and all but eagle-eyed fans were
more focused on that oversized flannel
because scott has the same exact one
but the flannel saga doesn't stop there
in june
scott commented cute shirt on this photo
of courtney in wyoming but on a serious
note
a new promo for keeping up with the
kardashians just dropped and
things get heated there couldn't have
been a bigger betrayal
she leaked me being there to the press i
don't trust anybody here
scott doesn't specifically see what that
leak was but the timing lines up with a
brief rehab stint
the father of three entered a treatment
facility in may
reportedly for ongoing help with his
mental health but left
shortly after the news broke a photo of
scott at the private facility was
released to the media
which might be what he's referring to at
the time a source told
et that courtney and sophia influenced
his decision to seek help
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
but it takes hard work whatever the case
will be tuning in to keeping up to find
out just
what went down when it returns to e in
[Music]
september